le tennis fauteuil à l'honneur à
feucherolles le comité des yvelines
organise un tournoi sur trois jours du
26 au 28 novembre avec au programme des
matches entre 16 des meilleurs joueurs
français une première pour un comité de
tennis nous avions un projet fort au
niveau du tennis fauteuil sur le comité
et c'était une façon de consolider
justement ce projet et puis de donner
une image un haut niveau du tennis
fauteuil pour attirer justement
davantage nos participants à ce niveau
là le comité les i mean compte à ce jour
trois sportifs intégré la cellule au
niveau mise en place par la structure
pour préparer les sportifs aux
compétitions internationales et aux jeux
paralympiques de 2024 on retrouve
notamment pauline déroulé de la
championne de france 2021 participer à
cette compétition j'étais ravi de jouer
ici voilà c'est mon lieu d'entraînement
le comité des yvelines donc c'est un peu
la maison j'ai pas fait
j'ai pas joué comme je voulais chez
voilà j'ai un nouveau fauteuil et c'est
vrai que je prenais encore mes marques
et puis voilà un peu fatigué de la
saison mais je suis contente d'avoir
remporté la troisième place pour honorer
un podium pour pour mon comité la
sportive seules féminines présentes ce
jour là finalement terminé à la
troisième place de cette édition c'est
un très bon niveau voilà c'est des
garçons qui savent jouer au tennis qui
ont l'habitude l'expérience des tournois
voilà moi ça me permet de me confronter
à un très bon niveau voilà ça me fait
dans ça le fait bien jouer après il ya
des petits détails qui joue au mental
parfois une nouvelle édition de ce
tournoi seront organisées l'année
prochaine dans les yvelines à l'avenir
le comité des yvelines espèrent pouvoir
recevoir des sportifs internationaux sur
ces terrains